facing the marlins for the fourth
straight time in the first three he's
three
a 1-0 with a 1.50 era and the mets
have uh really gotten used to winning
with degrom
on the mound lately dickerson hits the
first pitch in the ear to center field
jake marisdick patrolling out there and
it requires just one pitch for degrom to
get the first out of the day
he jams cooper who rolls one out to
rosario
and that's the second out
they have cranked up the fake crowd
noise today
2-2 coming and he struck him out he went
around on the half swing on the slider
and degrom has his first strike out at a
one two three
opening inning 2-2 coming
and he struck him out got him with a
slider so
long with his legs and his arms the
glove
meets that knee as he's leaning forward
and watch how long he holds on to that
baseball we talk about
effective velocity i mean he's letting
that ball go at 54 feet
one two coming and diaz lifts one out to
left center
and dom smith settles under it and
that's the second out
you could make that argument that the
grom is in the top three of all pitchers
in baseball with his big three
and he takes care of vr six up and six
down for degrom
with three strikeouts two two on the way
and he gets him with the slider the grom
loving his slider today that's his
fourth strike after the first seven
batters
and he strikes out alfaro with a
fastball away that's five strikeouts
through the first eight batters for jake
gotta hit four straight games looking to
keep that modest hit streak alive
rolls one left side that's rosario
and brinson is safe an
infield single for louis brinson rosario
ranging into the hole i'll tell you
right now princeton was flying down the
line he's going to get going and
all right there you go sweet lou finding
a way
[Applause]
runner goes throw is not in time
brinson gets around the tag of rosario
and it's a stolen base
i'm not waiting around on degrom kind of
gave you the numbers the marlins have
had a lot of success against ramos the
mets pitching staff this year
1-2 coming to cooper
struck him out the ground blows the
fastball by
cooper to get himself out of trouble
three strikeouts in the inning six on
the day for jake
so here's mcneal the corners are in
against him
as though he might be bunting which he's
not
jeff struck out his first time up
yeah he should move back brian anderson
and towards the hole a little bit
wide move vr back too yeah nice and too
tight
that's pulled over the bag and that's a
base it down the line and that'll get
the mets the lead
rosario scores nimmo heads to third
dug out by joyce nimmo will stop at
third it's an rbi double for jeff mcneal
and the mets are in front one nothing in
the third
good call by rojas lets mcneal swing
away
and his ground ball finds a hole
now they bring the infield up
they did not bring it in for alonso but
they do bring it in for smith
and dom lifts one out to right that'll
get a run home at least back toward the
corner goes
joyce he gets there and makes the catch
nimmo
tags he'll come in to score mcneal goes
to third on the sacrifice fly by dom
smith rbi number 26 for dom
and a two-nothing mets lead in the third
he swings and misses a strikeout
his fifth and a big out number two yeah
great job going up against the hottest
mets hitter
dominic smith he's in clutch with
runners in scoring position
this season see the breaking ball
there's the change up worked itself
down into the strike zone set up nicely
by the fastball away
right in there again three and two ramos
in on the hands this one out to center
vr makes the catch
yes he hangs on twisting and turning
into right center field
jonathan vyar puts it away
and that'll get us to the sixth a few
moments ago
jonathan vr and don mattingly talking
now ken rosenthal of
the athletic and mlb network fox sports
and everything else one of the best
around says that
vr is going to the blue jays so still a
ball game here
two nothing to score top of the sixth
and cooper with a fly ball this one is
gonna go
wow into the second deck and left
a one run game back to back-to-back
sliders and i'll tell you what coupe
probably had a pretty good feel for what
92
and a slider and that was not a good
slider from degrom looks like
we told you this afternoon he's really
been leaning on the pitch
and now lewin diaz toward right center
field that
is gonna get to the wall joyce comes
around to score
diaz into second with a ribby double
that ties things in the sixth
paulie i'm telling you lewin has got a
great swing i know the results have not
been there yet but his timing is coming
in a
huge hit for laywin maybe the biggest of
his young careers so far
it's hit hard and caught by a diving
mcneil
for the second half well his
responsibility was to keep the runner
close
but see how he backed up those four
steps
once the ball was delivered and that got
him in position
to make that play to his left it started
with a what they didn't start with
but there was a pete alonso error mixed
in after the garrett cooper home run
as alfaro hits one hard to right field
that'll head toward the corner
it brings home mickey rowe and another
double in the inning for the marlins
now this is the jorge we are so familiar
with when he
was at his best last year we would see
him at times take velocity and go the
other way with authority does it once
again against degrom
98 mile an hour fastball rockets it
into that right field corner robinson
canola leads off
and robbie cracks one out to left center
field back in the gap moves brinson near
the wall
it's out of here robertson can open an
opposite field home run
to get the bets back to within a run
sixth of the year for robbie and it's
now four to three miami
double and homer both against lefties
fastball
down and away and swiped out by canoe
and hit 390 feet amazing
all right they were they were ticked off
and rightly so yeah
over playing on this monday up in new
york we understand it could have been
reversed or playing at the end of the
year it didn't happen
oh brian anderson there it goes home run
and it's back to a two run lead for the
marlins
great extension on this cut fastball
inner third 86 miles an hour
[Applause]
a no doubter to left center
[Applause]
ideal time to face conforto
and a ground ball that's going to be
anderson to make the play
it's a marlins win